SI temple exclusive
our next speaker will be jihad thanks
thank you today I'm going to talk about
online floating optimization for
unrelated machines most of the basics
for flow time optimization was already
covered by kamesh and he presented an
algorithm proportional fairness which
sort of gives fairly good algorithm for
a large class of scheduling problems but
one special case when I say special case
don't take it as it's in a narrow sense
but an important official case of this
problem is unrelated machine scheduling
and for which the algorithm presented by
kamesh does not at least as of now we
don't understand whether it performs
well and that that special case is
unrelated machines which was introduced
by lens Dutch merchant orders within the
audience they wish noise in the audience
and so what's the problem here we are
given a set of machines and a set of
jobs and the reason we call it as
unrelated is that the properties of the
jobs in particular its processing length
depends on the machine so for example if
there is a job Jay it may take one unit
if you schedule on machine first machine
I it may take ten units if you schedule
on second machine and so on okay so
that's the reason why we call it as
unrelated machines and although this
model was introduced in 87 it is still
relevant even in the current scheduling
applications think of it as maybe if the
job has the data located on a particular
machine then it takes shorter duration
to complete and if it if the data is not
located then you have to fetch the data
so then it takes a longer duration to
complete so the model is highly relevant
even in today's applications and the way
we formalize it as the follows we think
every job as a processing length PJ and
this is the amount of the work job needs
to do but it has a speed SI j which
depends on the machine and the job I ok
so if you assign the job to machine I
object machine I then it runs at this
speed the speed is some quantity between
0 to 1 ok and the processing length I
will use this notation p IJ is pj work
as a pj / sha ok i will switch back and
forth between these two
the notations but for conciseness we
will use P IJ 2 denotes the processing
length of job J on machine I ok and what
is the unrelated machine scheduling
problem we are given the set of jobs and
a set of machines and you ought to
assign these jobs to minimize some
quality of service and this is perhaps
the the most well studied model in
scheduling theory and even in
approximation algorithms it has not only
practical relevance but it's also sort
of textbook stuff or in design of
approximation algorithms so for example
the lens Tosh monstre order surrounding
in it is 87 is really like the
prototypical application of LP rounding
and some of my favorite results in the
recent years like for example bansal
Maxim's result on Santa Claus rounding
and the the center class for unrelated
machine learning biola they are all
studied in the context of this problem
so both it has practical relevance but
it is arguably the most fundamental the
model in approximations and scheduling
theory okay and in this talk I'm mostly
interested in understanding the flow
time objective the object which was
already defined by commish and as I
already told the algorithm which was
proposed which was discussion the
previous talk doesn't actually give any
meaningful guarantees for this problem
okay so what's the plan the plan is to
like sort of so discuss the two
algorithms which argue curve which give
you meaningful competitive ratios for
this problem the one algorithm by
chatter Gargan kumar who is amit kumar
is in the audience and another non
clermont algorithm buy some gym and my
seventh commish and Kirk Bruce and we
will see the analysis of these
algorithms why the lens of duality the
commish proposed comma showed a
potential function based analysis but I
will show a duality based analysis and
then I will briefly touch upon some
connections to equilibrium concepts and
this is preemption over my vision ago
yes so I will I will briefly tell you
yes both preemption and migrations are
allowed just to recap what is the flow
time completion time minus the release
time and the work the you can also
represent the total flow time of the job
as the number
of jobs which are alive at time T so
this quantity will be useful in the
analysis so this is this is the formula
to keep in mind and this problem has a
long history starting from 1996 the
problem of the minimizing flow time has
been has been studied both in offline
and online settings I don't want to go
into details but one thing to note is
that the many of the earlier result
applied only in identical machines
related machines and restricted
assignment setting but not really in the
unrelated machine setting the results
for unrelated machine scale settings
asked to have been only recent work and
the reason for this is the flow time is
a very brittle objective like if you
perturb the input by a bit then the
objective function completely changes
and this poses a lot of technical
challenges in the analysis so for
example even in the offline setting we
did not know any approximation
algorithms for unrelated machines it was
recently give was given in my work with
bouncer but today's of course I am only
going to talk about online and in the
online setting its you know about the
job when it arrives okay so the the set
of the machines are already given to you
and on the job comes you learn these two
parameters SI j in pj okay so the goal
is to assign to minimize average flow
time or the total flow time as someone
asked earlier so what what are the
assumptions we are making we are we
assume that the jobs can be preempted on
a single machine the scheduling policy
can Priam jobs this is necessary without
that you cannot get any meaningful
results even in the offline setting and
the jobs can also be migrated you mean
the jobs can be processed in a machine
for some some duration of time but you
can switch this assignment or the the
course of its execution but the
important property you might be thinking
said then what else is left so important
properties that at any time you are
assigning job to only single machines
that's the most crucial thing so
physically you can't process the same
job on multiple machines so that is that
is not allowed okay and we do the
standard competitive analysis where we
measure the cost worst-case the cost of
the algorithm and in particular for flow
time problems you cannot base
without this what is so-called resource
document ation or speed augmentation you
cannot get any meaningful guarantees so
we compare ourselves with the algorithms
which have 1 plus epsilon speed whereas
the opt is restricted to the the speed
of one okay so this is mostly for the
sake of analysis algorithms themselves
don't depend on this thing so that's a
nice thing this is a purely and analysis
technique ok any questions so far so
this is the problem we are going to
study for this remainder of this talk so
we are given set of unrelated machines
the jobs have pij the value p IJ on it
and the goal is to the design algorithms
which are good for the flow time
objective yes augmentation is useful so
okay so the okay well the way I think it
resource augmentation is separating
between good algorithms from bad
algorithms in the worst-case analysis if
you do a worst-case analysis for these
problems all algorithms do not be
equally bad so they say that competitor
a show of any algorithm cannot be more
than n for example or order of n so then
your but then clearly we observe that
self some algorithms are better than the
others and how do you separate good
algorithms from the bad so you like you
give i will give you some extra resource
then some algorithms perform
significantly better than the other and
that gives a good separation and for me
analysis is all about which algorithm is
better than the other so that is one
there is also queuing theoretical
evasion for it but I don't want to get
into that okay any other questions okay
so first i will present the first round
liner oh yes migration and preemptions
both come at no cost okay but we will
see that we don't migrate too much I
mean we can bound how much we migrate
sir okay so i will quickly want to
review this very elegant algorithm by
category and Kumar I'm citing two things
this algorithm was proposed in stock
paper in 09 but it was a more elegant
proof was given in soda result by subset
of the earth same authors and the
algorithm for the for the unrelated
machines in online setting and so if you
if you think
this problem for a bit what are the two
decisions and on and algorithms has to
do for minimizing flow time so you have
to take two decisions one is if I tell
you the subset of the jobs Azonto
machine how do you schedule them and
then another decision you need to take
is what are the subset of jobs which go
to a particular machine so there is an
assignment the decision you need to take
and there is a scheduling decision you
need to take okay so these are the two
important decisions and online algorithm
has to make and if you are familiar with
this literature then the first question
is not too difficult to solve because on
a single machine if you want to minimize
flow time and I if you recollect the
flow time is just the number of jobs
alive at a particular time T so then
basically you want to finish the jobs as
quickly as possible so one way to the
loosely speaking what you want to do is
to schedule smaller jobs and you finish
them fast so that the number of jobs
remaining at a time is small ok so the
shortest remaining time first is sort of
a good rule but the crux of the most of
the algorithms including algorithms I'm
gonna present today is the assignment
what are the subset of jobs which go to
the machines and this is a really
difficult question in unrelated machine
settings because the jobs are really
different characteristics on the
machines thank you okay yes yes sorry
yes yeah this algorithm by chat again
could Kumar really does not need
migration so I'm presenting two
algorithms one clairvoyant and one non
clairvoyant so this algorithm does not
need so this rule is well defined okay
and and it's what is the assignment
policy and and in this paper of their
proposed of following very
simple-looking assignment policy what
they say is that since I am already
scheduling jobs based on the SRP tirol
it gives an ordering of the jobs on a
particular machine when when a job comes
you just assign you pretend you do this
thought experiment I will assign these
jobs to different machines and see how
much the flow time increases because the
first tool is already fixed you can
calculate this quantity and they say
that okay assign this job to the machine
which increases the object to buy
the least so it is a greedy policy and
this is the one short assignment that
never change the assignment of the jobs
but this crucially needs the knowledge
of the processing length because they
are pt rule itself needs the processing
length of the jobs it's a brilliant
algorithm I mean if you see the
literature before this algorithm leaders
quite complicated and they came up with
okay so let me just illustrate if it is
was not clear suppose this was the queue
of the too much the jobs and the two
machines when a new job comes off the
length 20 you just assign it to the
first machine then you can calculate the
increases 31 + 20 which is 51 and if you
assign the job on the second machine the
increase is 4068 so you will choose the
sign the job to the first machine and
execute in the shortest job first order
okay and they show that this algorithm
this lead what I call it as a greedy
algorithm is 1 plus epsilon speed 1 over
epsilon competitive for minimizing total
weighted flow time so initially they
gave a very nice potential function
argument and in the sword or 12 paper to
buy even more sophisticated a dual
pitting argument and both of them are
extremely nice i and i highly recommend
reading them okay but 11 I wouldn't say
I drawback but the limitation of this
algorithm is that it mean it usually
depends on knowing the values of the PJ
and by that I mean even if you give even
if I give an estimate of the PJ I don't
know exactly what's the value of PJ but
I will it may be between two pj 24 PJ
then the algorithm needs more speed so
it is not graceful in that sense and and
estimating the values of PJ is a really
difficult problem in real-world
applications so one of the problems one
of the important problems in the online
flow time literature was that can there
be an algorithm which is non clairvoyant
which does not even look at the values
of the PJ but it knows the values of the
SI j the speed of the job on a machine I
and still get a good competitive
algorithms okay and we show in our work
that there is such an algorithm indeed
and we call it a selfish my great and it
almost achieves the same guarantee that
if you give me 1 plus epsilon speed we
can we can show an algorithm which is 1
over epsilon square competitive
in the in the full information setting
it was one over epsilon and in this
number one setting is one of epsilon
square but pretty much except that it is
the same al its it matches the bound but
there is one important difference here
the migration is necessary someone was
asking me this before so here the
migration is necessary and without
migration you can't achieve any come any
meaningful guarantees okay so this this
this algorithm actually reassigns jobs
over the course of its execution okay I
would again so there are even in around
thorough and sitting there are two
decisions to make so let me describe
what is the algorithm so the first
decision is the scheduling policy and
the scheduling policy itself has to be
non clairvoyant now because we do not
know the processing length so so the
scheduling policy on meech machine is
the simple round-robin algorithm okay so
okay so I'm I'm cheating a bit here
because round-robin actually does not
give you 1 plus epsilon thing but it is
a modification of round-robin but it's
not it's not too much of a modification
okay and if people if you are if you
don't know whats around robbing
algorithm it basically shared CPU
equally among all the jobs okay if there
were any jobs at a particular time T
then it assigns 1 over n fraction to the
each each job okay so but but the
crucial thing which was like the
bottleneck for designing algorithms in
and out there when setting is what is
the assignment of jobs to machines since
you basically don't know the processing
lands and the flow time is so much
dependent on like assigning calculating
these quantities like the increase in
the objective it was not at all clear
what is the good assignment of the jobs
to machines and we overcome by doing
this following thought experiment we
basically set it up as a game okay so we
we think that ok every job is trying to
minimize its own flow time and it sort
of tries to assign itself to the job to
the machine which sort of gives it a
good rate ok I will make it precise but
the overall thing is that we don't
explicitly calculate the assignment we
set it up as a game between jobs and
machines and an equilibrium
come of this game will be assignment of
the jobs two machines okay for that I
need the notions of virtual queues and
job behavior i will describe it in few
slides but i want to i want to pass for
a bit and tell that this is all just for
the assignment ok so the scheduling
policy on the each machine is already
fixed i am going to do round robin but
i'm setting up this as a game just to
find the assignment of the jobs to
machines okay so okay so what is to
define this game I need the notion of
q's every job maintains set this Q our
jobs it's basically a FIFO queue okay
every job which wants to move from one
machine to another is free to move but
if it moves then it has to go at the end
of the queue okay so in our algorithm
this the jobs can migrate at any time
there it's like the job decides to move
from one machine to another but whenever
it moves it has to go at the tail so we
let the jobs to migrate at any time okay
but what is not allowed is like if the
job moves to another machine it joins in
the middle of the queue so that's not a
lot so basically it behaves like a FIFO
queue ok and now why do jobs wants to
change machine assignments it's it's
based on this quantity what we call as
virtual rate so every job wants to
maximize this virtual rate if you think
this has the utility of the jobs
basically and this quantity is basically
is the speed of the job on the machine i
divided by the position of the job in
the virtual queue okay so this is sort
of a proxy for how much rate this job
gets on the machine I since we are doing
round-robin this quantity is related to
the number of the jobs on that machine
so this is proxy for how much weight I
would get if i move to the machine i
note that if this was NT which is number
of jobs at time T then it would be
exactly the rate the job gets but this
is not quite the same but that's that's
the intuition for for this rule so see
if the job gets executed faster at a
particular time it's on its own floating
minimizes so that sort of is the
intuition for why every job wants to
wants to minimize this maximize this
quantity okay so so what so this is the
virtual rate of the job
and every job wants to get assigned to
the machine which maximizes this virtual
rate okay so for example if the job Jay
was on machine one the fee fee one JT at
time T will be like one over third one s
1 J by 3 because it has its position is
it is three in this queue and it's pdz
Sanjay but if it can move to the machine
to if it wants but then it's fee will be
this quantity because it has to go at
the tail of the the Q okay so so okay so
every the algorithm sort of implicitly
defines this game where every job is
trying to maximize this the virtual rate
okay so what is the assignment so the
assignment is the outcome of this game
where eat where each job chooses the
machine which maximizes this quantity
simultaneously what it means that as an
assignment is valid in my in my
scheduling policy if at this current
configuration of the jobs every every
job is assigned to the machine which is
maximizes think quantity okay maybe are
in game theoretic terms this is
basically the Nash equilibrium if I took
this as the utility of the job okay but
some of you might be like worried at
this point because it's not clear a
priori why such an equilibrium outcome
should exist at all so is this algorithm
well define it is well defined if I show
that simultaneously everybody can be
assigned to the machine which maximizes
this quantity right in other words there
is a unique now there is a pure Nash
equilibrium for this game and that is
fairly fairly easy to prove suppose at
time T there is a Nash equilibrium if
nothing no event happens no job comes or
leaves then at time T plus 1 there will
be an equilibrium but there are two
events which can change this changes
quantity that is the arrival of a job or
a departure of the job and the job
completes the arrival is an not at all a
problem because when a job arrives it
goes at the tail and the way this
quantity was defined only dependent of
this was dependent on the jobs which are
ahead of it so this quantity for the
other jobs does not change at all so
that still will be a Nash equilibrium so
this is fairly simple but the more
interesting thing happens when a job
complete suppose
job completes here then the cuse get
sort of rearranged and my fee quantity
keeps changing so maybe job starts
deciding to move from one machine to
another and so there will be a best
response dynamics well that's what we
call in game theory so the jobs can keep
changing the assignment and i want to
show you that this actually converges
this cannot keep on going forever and
this follows from fairly simple
observation because why did the job move
a job mood because it's fidgety
increased so it's virtual rate increased
but when it moves it always moves at the
tail so it does not change the fee
values of the other jobs so there
nothing changed and in the queue it
departed from they sort of slide in so
it can also go up so whenever a job
moves it keeps growing so the Nash
equilibrium exists you just take this as
the potential in fact this is the
potential game so there will always be
an escape librium but there is another
important crucial fact which is will be
used in the analysis is that the virtual
rate of the job not just in the
assignment but if the entire course only
keeps going up it monotonically keeps
increasing it never decreases and this
monotonicity is important for this
analysis and if you try to connect to
the previous talk that was the thing
which we did not have in the PF
allocation for leontief utilities for
example so the monotonicity somehow
plays an important role it's not that
it's not a yeah yes that job is
completely finished when it goes back in
the line right no so this is just to
figure out what is the assignment of the
job so I'm just defining how the jobs
are assigned to machines so once you
once you give me the assignment
everybody every job is every machine
scheduling based on round-robin always
never decrease I mean to be best after
the runs for a while it's putting the
last in the queue yes but the point is
that that's the way we define this
quantity because ok ok so so if suppose
the job was assigned to a particular
machine let's say this right if it
sticks to this machine itself it never
changes his assignment
then what can happen is the front of the
queue starts depleting right so then its
virtual rate only keys goes up because
the way the quantity virtual rate was
defined is basically this n over T which
is the number of position of the job in
the queue right if you just talk to the
machine it was in this quantity would
not have decreased No so that's that was
the crucial thing yes so this is just to
figure out the assignment it's not
nothing to do with the way job search
process okay good question all right so
okay so basically we prove that the Nash
equilibrium exists and in particular we
need this for the analysis so in the
rest 10 minutes I have I will give you
the proof of how these algorithms are
analyzed and these algorithm both the
greedy algorithm endesha okay so so
there were two components to the the
scheduling algorithm one was the
assignment of the jobs and another was
another was how the jobs are scheduled
on a processed on a particular machine
so the jobs are processed using
round-robin it has nothing to do with
queues and how jobs migrate at all right
if you tell me what are the subset of
jobs that are resign we just use the
round robin to schedule them but the way
to figure out the assignment of the jobs
we thought we did this thought
experiment where we set it as of a game
between jobs and machines and which all
dependent on this virtual rates and so
on and the outcome of this a Nash
equilibrium of this game will give me an
assignment so in today to understand I
guess the problem is we assign a job to
some machine what you don't know the
size is right so this queue that looked
bad I mean it could become very good
maybe cover that's why you want to move
yes yeah exactly yeah so because if if
some machine starts looking good the
queue sort of decreasing then I want to
start moving jobs to those machines so
this is one way to do it yeah just right
now according to this rule the job might
you know oscillate magic between
cuse if you know one guy decreases yeah
right now there's no bound on the number
of migrations but maybe you'll do
something yes okay so let me I I don't
have that thing here but we can show
that every job in its entire course
don't does not migrate more than log log
log p log of some processing length so
the reason is very simple instead of
moving whenever my rate increases i will
move only 1 plus epsilon rate increases
then that that basically ok any other
questions on the algorithm all right so
so I will present an analysis or are we
try to sketch the proof of this these
algorithms using duality so this is
another analysis technique which has
been dominant in analysis of scheduling
algorithms and the potential function is
one of the the main tools we use and the
duality has recently duality has been
also been used to analyze the algorithms
and the way to analyze is fairly
standard which is common in
approximation algorithms you write you
formulate the problem as an optimization
problem and you write the duo and we
know these these inequalities and how
the primal-dual and the opti late and
you basically try to show that since i
have already have an algorithm you try
to produce a dual feasible solution
which sort of ties with the the cost of
the algorithm that is fairly the idea so
so for this primal the LP is basically
the one to minimize the flow time of the
jobs I don't want to get into too much
details because we don't really use the
primal LP too much but there are two
natural constraints that this first
constraint basically says that the job
has to be completely processed and the
second constraint says that at any time
on every machine there is only one unit
of the job being process and this
objective function is somewhat
non-trivial because we don't we can't
write completion times or flow times as
a linear objective but this gives a
lower bound I don't want to get into the
details but it is also called as
fractional flow time but this is fairly
standard and it has been used in
other places okay and the duel has this
nice structure where there is one one
variable alpha J corresponding to this
primal constraint that every job gets
finished and there is one variable beta
IT which basically corresponds to the
second constraint and the duel has this
following form where you want to
maximize summation over alpha J minus
summation or beta IT subject to this
constraint so let me zoom this in where
for each machine for every for every job
for each job and each time slot there is
a constraint okay so there is one
variable alpha J and this quantity which
needs to be satisfied at every time T
for every machine and the both the
greedy algorithm and the selfish man
rate algorithm I propose to have some
common characteristics they interpret
beta I T as the number of jobs alive in
my schedule okay or the total weight of
the jobs alive in my schedule so then if
you set beat IT to be that this can also
be read arrived using primal dual
methods but I'm just presenting is a
dual fitting idea then this this term in
the in the the duel looks like the total
flow time because recollect that the
flow time is basically number of jobs
alive at time T so if I set beta I t to
be this parameter then this objective is
the total flow time and somehow you also
want to say that alpha J I can set it in
a such a way that the first term is also
approximately equal to the total flow
time of the jobs and if you did
basically you give okay I mean if you
exactly prove that it is equal to the
total flow time than the dual objective
is 0 which is meaningless but then you
use some scaling tricks which is common
in approximation algorithms and here the
scaling also depends on the speed
actually the speed of the speed given to
the to the algorithm and that is very
crucial without that you basically can't
show any any any positive dual objective
okay so but that will be the plan you
want to set the total you want to set
alpha J is roughly corresponding to the
total weighted flow time of the jobs
and and if you think about bit in the
proof of chatter gurgaon kumar or on and
the Gorgon kumar in the soda paper they
set alpha j to be the increasing the
dual objective and a job arrived and
that is quite natural because this
quantity pj x beta IT is basically the
number of jobs and it's my processing
length on the machine I and if you think
if in the SRP thiru when I insert a job
the amount it increases is exactly the
my length times the number of the jobs
because all the jobs ahead of me or at
most my size and that all the jobs
behind me will push back by my
processing length so this quantity looks
exactly this thing and the basically
argue that if you set this then the dual
constraints will be satisfied and and my
the primal object will be like 1 over
epsilon times epsilon times the cost of
my schedule you can also interpret it by
primal dual analysis but this is the
this is the main observation but the
things become a lot more tricky okay so
so if I did that then it is a cost of
the algorithm so we want to we also want
to do the same we want to relate this
alpha J 2 to the cost of the my schedule
but it becomes a lot more tricky in our
case since we don't know we don't have a
good handle on how alpha G behaves so
that's the crux but I will try to now
give a proof of how we set our alpha J
variables and remember what we want to
show is that so alpha J some is
approximately related to the cost of my
algorithm but more importantly also need
to verify that this alpha J all the
constraints are satisfied I mean the way
I want to think is that there is one
variable alpha J but there are
constraints corresponding to each
machine right so you you set this
variable but at every time you want to
simultaneously say that these these
constraints are satisfied to define
alpha J we need two quantities which is
we call which we denote by Delta one so
the Delta one basically is so at time T
there is a job Jay and you think the
presence of this job hurts other jobs
because because of this
job some amount of the the processing
unit is given to this so because of the
job because of this job every other job
gets slowed down right i mean so the
presence of the jobs take away the cpu
from other things so so what we want to
measure is that the Delta 1 of T at time
T is the the total increase in the flow
time the job J causes and other jobs in
its entire course of the of the schedule
and the first lemma we show is that this
quantity is sort of inversely
proportional to the the fee right and
this is one intuition which everybody
saw every every job was trying to
maximize this quantity I want to keep
this quantity minimum smaller because I
want to keep that my dual objective is
small or the flow time to be small so I
want to keep this this quantity small
which means that I want to maximize this
quantity so this is this is one
motivation to define this game and this
proof of this crucial uses the
monotonicity of the fee function okay
and the second the term we need is the
the Delta 2 of T which is basically the
total increase in the flow time the job
as caused till now on other jobs till
time T you fix a time T then you look at
all the previous time steps and you see
how much this job made the other slow
down the other jobs okay and we we show
that delta 2 of T is at most WJ x t
minus rj so and both of these proofs
needs the the monotonicity of the fee
function okay and now we define alpha j
basically equal to delta 1 T plus delta
2 T but you might be like okay confused
a bit because this Delta 1 and Delta to
have tea as a parameter but alpha JS is
independent of that but we could show
that for any time T this Delta one of
the sort of keeps decreasing and alpha J
at all times we can show that this is at
most this quantity okay and now and now
how do I prove that this constraint is
simultaneously satisfied
and here we use the Nash equilibrium
idea so basically so the alpha J you can
if you think of each constraints as a
strategy I was trying to minimize alpha
J and I and the alpha J is minimized and
the fee jetty is maximized so since
every job was on a particular machine
which maximize this vjt so so the so
this constraint is tied for the machine
on which it is assigned and it is a it
has a slack on every other machine so
this is roughly the Nash equilibrium
condition and that again pops out of the
dual the dual constraints okay so that
basically completes the proof and I
think interesting take away from this is
the interplay of like this equilibrium
ideas which come out of the duality
constraints and this this is not a
coincidence in some some sense there are
other places where we could use this
exactly the same idea and show good
algorithms for example in particular the
another line of work which has been
popular in scheduling theories to
minimize flow time plus the energy and
almost the same algorithm works and
recently we extended some of the results
these results for multi-dimensional
setting the setting which kamesh
presented earlier okay so okay so i have
1 1 minute ok so i just want to tell one
more i might want to make one more
comment regarding connections between
equilibrium and ideas and duality is
that so the way we set this up as a Nash
equilibrium is the outcome and we
analyze the quality of the Nash
equilibrium here it was all for the sake
of the coming up with an algorithm but
there is an entire literature which sort
of tries to understand the quality of
the Nash equilibriums and that's the
price of energy analysis and perhaps we
can also use the same technique the
duality technique to the bound the price
of analysis where we write the the
primal program and we try to relate the
cost of a Nash equilibrium with the cost
of the
a producer dual certificate and so in
fact this this analysis has been used in
our work and I think this is also a good
sort of like a unifying way to look at
these things like the duality arises out
of the equilibrium conditions and are
equal or in the other way like the
equilibrium conditions out of the
duality constraints and they they help
in the design of the algorithm and
that's that set
let's engine